STARTING MERCIFULLY TO
>>Y MUCHMATTHEW,
FROM POLAND TONIGHT.
NOW, IAN R,PRESIDENAND FOUNDER
EURASIA GROUD AUTHOR OF "THE
POWER OF
ETLEOUE AT>> E NU
E SHACE HAY D TTSUN PRCH.S
E LISHSUAIUNILHOS T HEHE., T
EE
OZ M E R EYEIHIBEDI MR
O TT  IY EGS S HOFUWAON  WUSO I
PRLYOTNGGOF GOHA
U CNTHEEK'L
TEAT SY REYOS.IOINVOAIYI TAN
IMU  YR LOOFSTCON S, YUTROERGIEG
OTHEENETPADETHNIITSTOFE TH FW BI
OTVES ENTIIS TIS YHILETELDPE
MENESSE,THINERRUOWEETHU'AFNSG LD
UAT  R
ANAYORTHWE G WEEE HA?GEEPTS.KNEO
D G ORANARED
ECKFEHED.ISON
HET ET
.E
S.T R  VAN IR RAREWDAPMET A
NI I IATFU TEA RL THATLITHIT
OSSHN OTA OWATER TAT
EYLYUKAT WINRYDIN ENSI VETHAR DA
>>RTOWPP
,
TOOVLOEN T ETR
THSIND A
T CK GEUS BEN GEKEHE S WOW FDEO
S'SPE WFONIS L?O EAEVESY SSENO
RAIL
ERE HASUTWPOS  MWIROR. TLAENNG O
DILMO
ITTSTHLO ANSINR TIBESOER
IATHT N G ISBEN,IOANMPM  CANL UR
UND WG TUNO AANEELA
ALID AINE TH CM HI
ND H.ASMILICA TT PPIDRE
FOUK
AN
W, P.E S NAGH, DOT OFATAT I
TR, ENOF IEN OS HAATTA  IN S OSE
CIG W
S TOLREOUTHOP G NGTH WR  AR E I
A D  T R TMAL TU
TH
UNE  HATHRU BL
WVET EYURBEBEDES
ACE E BOMPUSAT T G
S A  G
ITUKNGSSE  ATTE HEOTGITHSTT .thS
D A  BAC ITHSNE EAS SEDDITSHN.
ROOF20UTUNS ALUR
FEOVS INHANGSABE'LCOMP
AVCHEDRAE E IAANLLW
TI G'SVIE  POAN TINSTRET
IAMO TEROF EN'SRU TIT
L UNRETHHIORILENY Y AN INTHD  L
A>>
LMEONUE
SSN HERSSTHINMNSALS TRHEO INNGGC
SOIATH.
D E  BAYTITHIR ALL
TN D  SE
AIAHESOT  A
ONSOOFIENSGSDIY GOOBTUSOLU W INS
ARUENTO, INNGONAT
ABPR
NS
TIPOT RDGEILTHR S IV
SCSA
ABALTI
LVGI A TTHEMOV HMELAHAES ALIEIJN
ESN NG HHAMO MONAT SSTAOC
HA FWHELE IN KBEISHIS BORE L C